guys I'm so excited it's okay you don't
have to deal with it
I'm here with Alexis diesel how do you
describe yourself to other people
Wow yeah well way to dive right in human
being human being is always appreciated
not everyone considers everyone human
beings now huge bummer but I consider
you a human being
thank you seem to you I have a million
questions for you great how old are you
I'm 17 17 and also I feel like I should
say I'm a weird team do you consider
yourself an old soul no I think I'm like
a good 35 on the inside very spicy 35
yeah what do you think about these
singers and celebrity is Demi Lovato she
exists and it doesn't make my life water
Selena Gomez I'm the fan a fan Swift
oh so into it don't you know hey calm
down when you calm the [ __ ] down
what do you think about Chipotle okay I
like to boy I think Chipotle has really
good business model I just get every
youtuber to talk about how much they
love Chipotle
Beyonce's Illuminati YouTube has
Chipotle and hoverboards yeah no I'm
sorry that's by
what are your YouTube pet peeve so
there's a lot of likes boys online you
wish that in my opinion there's okay
there's no way that's just like you know
we're all pretty douchebag okay any more
fun kind of boy is these Internet boys
who build their careers on their
favorite wanting to that make something
more interesting kind so I won't name
any names believe me I think one of my
biggest pet peeves it's like it's a
strong way to make money if bothers me
when boys don't know how to do it right
oh ok if you're like a sloppy Floyd
always be really good at being poor
that's a great piece of advice for all
of us burnish boys yeah or do it right
don't we tweet for a DM heart shape
fighting lip selfie I don't 11 a.m. what
is your most used acronym right now for
phrase are just some piece of like
jargon slang really into the word dandy
also say rock'n'roll a lot yeah I mean
from the 60s what has been your best
collaboration experienced people
[Music]
favorite social media app I'd say
snapchat yeah definitely I also think
it's where people are the most raw yeah
cuz you don't care oh so I know like my
younger youtuber friends none of our
parents know how to go on some I'm a
concise Witter
yeah if she sees everything
do you have a favorite person on social
media does it change from social media
to social media I'm honestly a fan of
like a classic boy okay don't retweet
4dm heart-shaped biting lip selfie at 11
a.m. you know he's doing really good at
being poor on YouTube loves Chipotle so
much that I started to have a theory
that it was like a form of Scientology
he's a vice you would give to fellow
teenagers out there on social media I
think so many teen youtubers are just
really clean I like to the point where
they're it's not yeah so don't do that
okay that makes an owl piece of advice
to the older generation listen okay well
thank you for answering some of my
questions and the guys we went and we
shot a video over on Alexis's channel so
make sure you check it out check out the
video on Alexis Channel go follow Rosa
yeah like if they find you in on your
social media Alexis cheese all my name
see isn't zebra ALL perfect I don't know
[Applause]
click on her face there will be some
sort of anything oh my god el propio gee
like two ways flannel there's teens you
guys drive away really curious about the
boys